je ne peux pas
tha
tam tam
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est pareil en produits un
peu exceptionnel un produit qui est tout
nouveau je vous parle d'un produit qui
n'est pas encore lancée qui est un
prototype qui est une version
d'ingénieurs que j'ai juste à côté de
moi ce produit s'appelle le asus zenbook
17 fold oled alors je le prends vraiment
avec précaution parce que c'est un seul
peuple d'ingénieurs c'est pas du tout
aux produits définis il y en a un seul
ici on n'a pas dû le faire vraiment
extrêmement attention alors comme on est
sur un produit qui tout nouveau qu'il
n'ya pas d'être présenté il ya quelques
bugs il est encore en cours de
développement sur certaines
fonctionnalités c'est un produit qui
sortira mi 2022 on connaît pas encore le
prix mais tout ce qu'on voit ce qui est
vraiment génial et bien c'est que c'est
la première fois que asus nous sort un
ordinateur pliable alors je vous avait
déjà présenté stérile 1ère est un
produit de lenovo c'est le thinkpad
folle j'ai mangé le mans exactement je
vais me en vidéo on l'a vu il ya un an
mais on était sur un produit qui est
plutôt sympa mais pas hyper hyper hyper
abouti si c'est à peu près la même chose
c'est à dire qu'on va avoir un clavier
qu'on va pouvoir retirer qui se connecte
en bluetooth et vous avez un énorme
écran alors qu'on peut venir utiliser
comme ça ouvert voyez donc là vous avez
un écran 17 pouces c'est vraiment énorme
on peut orienter dans un sens ou dans
l'autre voyez un plat et tourner et vous
venez le plier alors vous le payez
ensuite en faire très attention
lorsqu'on le pli vous le prenez vous le
plier comme ça vous avez donc avoir une
version avec un ordinateur qui est
totalement plié toujours ici votre
windows 11 vous allez pouvoir venir
utiliser ça n'est qu'en qui complètement
tactile donc on utilise à la main on
peut venir scrollé s'amuser sans aucun
problème donc ça c'est cool mais l'idée
c'est que lorsque vous voulez l'utiliser
en mode ordinateur et bien vous posez
votre clavier dessus et là hop qu'est-ce
qui se passe eh bien on change un peu de
conflits ensuite lorsque vous le prenez
que vous livrez vous peut donc soit
l'utiliser comme ça avant de plier et
pourquoi pas avec un multi fenêtres une
fenêtre ou une fenêtre en bas on peut
imaginer sont des multi-applications
sera par exemple quand vous mettez un
excellent va vous mettez world vous
pouvez également avoir le clavier vous
cliquez là vous avez un clavier qui
vient à s'ouvrir juste en bas donc c'est
assez rigolo et si vous le souhaitez
bien après vous l'ouvrez est derrière
vous dite option cheval et qui vient
s'ouvrir voilà comme ça donc là on le
prend pour le retourne on vient le
positionner comme ça et on le met sur
une table et ça vous fait un énorme
écran 17 pouces avec le clavier que vous
allez venir poser en face pouvait être
un peu à distance comme ça c'est
vachement intéressant c'est que vous
preniez votre écran grandes dalles vous
la poser un peu plus loin vous avez le
clavier devant vous taper dessus il ya
en fait plusieurs usages sacchi
vachement intéressant vous avez un grand
écran dès qu'un écran de 17,3 pouces et
du format 4/3 en résolution 2,5 cas où
alors vous le prenez en deux écrans ces
deux écrans de 12,5 pouces en 1920 par
1200 80 donc on peut l'utiliser
différentes manières au keynote vous
avez donc un clavier avec un pavé
tactile asus ergo sense c'est en
bluetooth ok why not je trouve très fin
à leur clavier tout fin ça c'est
vachement cool très léger donc si on
veut le poser à distance et guerre
bosser dessus on peut alors le sucre
qu'on peut venir éventuellement
reprocher c'est qu'ici le clavier va pas
surélevé donc en termes de confort pour
venir taper vous êtes vraiment à plat
des fois c'est pas mal de bien sûr élevé
alors si vous voulez mettre un petit
boudin dessous pourquoi passer à glee
sport peut venir l'essayer ce qui
intéresse dans son club et c'est que
vous avez un petit bouton on off sur le
côté pour venir à l'acte iv et le
désactiver ok why not bon son principe
c'est la découverte donc je trouve
plutôt sympa plutôt sexy la question des
usages maintenant qui va venir se
plonger derrière on verra c'est un peu
plus tard c'est un premier test un os
qui sortira donc on en reparlera
probablement sur la chaîne donc si vous
n'êtes pas abonné et vous venez cliquer
sur le petit bouton rouge que vous avez
juste en dessous si les rouches et vous
n'êtes pas abonné vous actionnez la
cloche comme ça vous serez notifié dès
qu une prochaine vidéo arrivera et ça
c'est vachement bien ici on a un écran
qui est certifié pantone certifie
également thaïlande pour venir lutter
contre la lumière bleue la fatigue
oculaire donc ça c'est cool un écran qui
est 100% dci p3 dolby vision hdr on a
quatre haut parleurs harman kardon avec
dolby atmos on en trouvait à l'avant une
caméra infrarouge avec windows et l'eau
pour venir déverrouiller façon sécurisée
sans ça c'est plutôt bien vous avez
également une nouvelle gamme de 5
mégapixels on est sur du hd ici n'aura
pas la meilleure résolution mais bon on
peut pas tout avoir et vous avez la puce
intel visual à sensing contrôleur qui
servira à la détection de l'utilisateur
donc lorsqu'on était cap l'utilisateur
qui regardent ailleurs et bien l'écran
va se mettre en veille il servira
également pour le réglage de la
luminosité pour la balance des couleurs
et sur votre cas vous avez technologie
asus 3d noise reduction qui va venir
réduit le bruit pour vous améliorer la
qualité lors vos appels en visio ce que
vous voulez appeler votre mémé votre
patron et ses votes mais votre patron
vous est balèze tout ça tourne sur un
intel core i7 c'est la série us on les
sort de la 12e génération on a une carte
graphique c'est l'italie 6e on aura pas
ici les meilleures performances en vidéo
c'est pas un ordinateur qui est fait
pour le gaming clairement nos
ordinateurs qui va plus prendre la
productivité pour de la modularité pour
venir se déplacer pour avoir un produit
complètement atypique on a ici sur les
orly a doctor c'est des personnes qui
veulent des bécanes totalement novatrice
nouvelle différente différenciante j'ai
pas le prix mais à mon avis ordinateur
comme ça on devrait entendre des 2500
3000 3500 euros c'est ce qu'il semble le
rendre vraiment logique vue l'innovation
vu le concept vu l'écran qui se plie
cias du sar vient de sortir beaucoup
moins cher en dessous des 2 1000 euros
là ils arriveront à le démocratiser mais
vu le produit je suis pas convaincu
provera à mon avis le tarif est quand
même relativement élevé mais ça me
semblerait normal une facture en plus de
ça vous avez deux ports usb cl
thunderball 4 qui vous serviront à dire
brancher un disque dur pour venir à
faire des sauvegardes pourquoi pas
fournir le recharger rapidement aussi
pouvoir brancher des moniteurs externes
si vous voulez rajouter un deuxième
écran 24 32 pouces ou que sais-je encore
et bien vous pouvez le faire pour venir
accroître les surfaces de travail ça
c'est vraiment intéressant on pourrait
regretter qui est que deux ports usb
c'est thunderball 4 on pourrait en
vouloir plus si par exemple on vient à
brancher un moniteur est un disque dur
n'y a plus place ont fait parvenir
rechange en même temps tu as un truc un
peu ballot mais j'imagine qu'une fois de
plus c'est bien c'est un tout nouveau
produit asus a dû forcément faire des
choix on a une petite prise jack micro
donc si vous dire brancher un casque un
micro pour venir à converser lors de vos
visio professionnelle et bien on peut
bien le faire en une batterie intérieur
de 75 watts heure et c'est un pc qui a
été co conçu avec une telle que la
certification intel et vaud alors moi je
vous dis ce produit là je trouve
intéressant parce que c'est l'innovation
plus en parle beaucoup d'écrans qui se
plie notamment au travers de smartphones
on va faire de plus en plus de form
factor et on voit que tout doucement
l'univers du pc arrive là dessus alors
on pourrait se dire est ce qu'on veut
vraiment d'écran qui se plie sur un pc
est ce qu'un intérêt ce que c'est cool
pour moi oui dans la mesure où on vend
un produit nomade est un produit
différent maintenant il faut que le
marché évolue pour que les marchés
soient vraiment différent vox est une
étape intermédiaire j'ai l'impression
par rapport à ce qu'on pourrait imaginer
d'un futur du pc en tout cas je pense à
une fois de plus assez cool le format
j'avais déjà vu avec le premier
s'appelait le lenovo thinkpad x1 fold
j'avais trouvé ça rigolo mais je n'ai
pas persuadé qu'il est encore un marché
si un acteur comme asus arrive dessus
avec une innovation comme ça c'est
évident qu'il ya un marché qui commence
à se dessiner il ya vraiment des
contours qui commence à se poser serait
pas forcément pour 2020 2 on est sur des
produits de niche réellement en tout cas
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ça
montre là où on peut aller ce qui peut
se passer pour l'univers du pc à
l'horizon 2023 2024 en tout cas très
très beau boulot asus eee très content
pouvoir découvrir ici aux crs dans une
toute petite suite de l'hôtel de ville
zhan il ya deux ans il avait un espèce
de pareils d'une très grande suite avec
plein de produits et dont vous pouvez
lire ce film et c'est ça la c'est très
très confidentiel il ya deux personnes
dans une suite il ya tous les produits
poser c'est intéressant je suis content
qu asus soit là ou sms pour qu'on puisse
voir ça à voir la possible de venir le
prendre en main de venir le découvrir il
ya plein d'autres nouveautés de asus
dont on reparlera bientôt sur youtube ça
c'est cool donc rester connecté si vous
l'avez pas déjà fait une fois de plus on
clique on s'abonne mais voilà moi j'aime
bien je trouve ça chouette ou que asus a
bien bossé nous propose un truc qui est
vraiment différent c'est très très grand
c'est vraiment très très grand mais pour
moi l'usagé est assez cool c'est lorsque
vous le plier comme ça et que vous venez
poser votre clavier dessus eh bien il ya
une transformation automatique qui
trouve sa place très facilement cognard
bocek votre windows rose comme ça et je
trouve ça marrant voilà en effet une
fois fermée aussi c'est pareil alors
c'est assez lourd et j'ai pas le poids
mais c'est un budget qui est assez
lourde qui est assez épaisse mais que je
trouve chouette est vrai une finition
avec un aspect cuir sur le dos sur je
sais pas si c'était du vrai cuir ou un
côté cuir végétal mais en tout cas c'est
l'âge où le produit est bien fini pour
voir qu'on est sur une version
d'ingénieurs on n'est pas sur une
version de production mais très chouette
j'aime beaucoup il ya un espèce de
reflets en plus convenir retrouver ici
c'est un an c'est beau suis pas
convaincu qu'ils en vendent des tonnes
je pense pas que ce soit le but non plus
je pense que l'idée c'est de montrer
l'innovation montré là où ils vont aller
mais je suis très surpris et très
intéressé par ce que asus a fait ici à
vous me dire ce que vous en pensez
comment vous trouvez vous est ce que
vous seriez prêt à aller sur un pc
pliable est ce que vous voyez lusage est
ce que vous pourriez vous projetez vous
dans votre vie de tous les jours à dire
ok je vais prendre un produit comme
celui là il ya un sens je veux en faire
quelque chose alors effectivement on dit
à l'écran qu'on peut venir utiliser là
j'ai un blues poussent comme ça avec mon
clavier dessus c'est quand même pas mal
faidherbe au cfa de la productivité et
lorsque j'ai besoin jouve le poste bas
ça me fait un grand écran de 17 pouces
pour le visionnage de service est très
cool mais venir m je connais pas la
somme mais j'imagine des sommes qui vont
être un peu cher sur un produit
uniquement pour aller des films des
séries en 17 pouces suis pas convaincu
mais l'idéal l'idée est bonne tout ça
coûte moi ce que vous en pensez bien
évidemment est donc très vite on
continue à parler de teck et ça c'est
cool j'embrasse des bisous à mettre
autre chose
[Musique]
à